it's time for drew's news the cozy good
news blanket on the back of your good
news couch and with me at the desk is my
coziest coziest co-pilot rossi rosnathia
hi everybody
all right before we get started the
money booth strikes again
[Applause]
okay so at the end of the show one
audience member is going to earn time in
the booth
and today we've got a twist all the
questions will come
from a very special guest in our digital
hub neil patrick harris yes
all right
why did we get into some headlines um
first up guess who just joined instagram
are you ready for this uh-huh
okay because he's one of the most
influential rappers in history he just
got inducted into the rock of rural hall
and fame this weekend he's a billionaire
he's a game changer it's jay-z welcome
people report
um that jay almost got 2 million
followers instantaneously
um and he follows just one account can
you guess what that one account is
come on right
beyonce
the first post that he did um was the
harder they fall um which is a new
netflix movie that he co-produced and
wrote music for it's a western starring
regina king and idris elba oh we'll all
be there for that oh yeah hello
and
yeah give roxy your thing well no i was
just gonna say didn't you just like get
to meet jay-z take a picture with him i
have met him before i um but i did just
get to hang out with him at the rock and
roll hall of fame look at that look
he said congratulations on the show
him and beyonce know about the show
rozzy
hi jay-z by the
my quick funny jay-z story is that i was
at the mtv um movie music something
awards many years ago
and um beyonce comes out and she's
singing crazy in love
and he's standing there at the monitor
and i'm standing at the monitor because
i'm going on after her and we're
watching her and he's like yeah you know
it's so funny she's you know just
hanging out and then just goes out there
and does all that and he's just like
looking at the monitor like my beautiful
wife and i was like oh my god that's so
closing crazy you know that you can like
you know just switch personalities like
that and we just started talking he's
like give me one second and he picks up
the microphone and goes out onto the
stage and does his part of the song and
i was like
oh i'm just such a fan of his as we all
are and when those moments happen i
don't feel like a cool hollywood insider
i feel like someone who is getting to
meet one of their heroes and i'm just
freaking out inside hoping that it
doesn't look too crazy on the outside no
that is so cool did you handle your cool
were you totally chill i mean i probably
look like this when i was telling the
story
that's how i felt inside
um i'm not cool i never am it's not i
don't ha that's not for me in this
lifetime but you know whatever no keep
it real i'm gonna follow him on ig you
guys can follow him yeah i'm in all
right up next we've got your tv plans
for november 19th mark this down rolling
stone reports that that day fx and hulu
are premiering malfunction the dressing
down of janet jackson yes
the entire nation's going to be watching
it it's going to be a rhythm nation
it's a documentary all about the
infamous super bowl moment between janet
and justin timberlake remember that the
dog breaks it down and the huge impact
it had on janet's career and it looks at
all the cultural and racial dynamics at
play as well i know drew i can't wait to
see this i do want to watch it i that
was such a mystery yes and there was
such
uh fallout from it and i would like to
understand
why this moment happened and
because all i know is that it was just a
complete take down so i just am like who
was involved who knew who is responsible
because this like really was a big deal
major pop culture moment and you
remember the what happened afterwards
and think about how much the culture has
shifted
since then and maybe because of this
moment and how would it go down if
something like that were to happen now
it's really affected our culture i mean
raise of hands from the audience like
who has a burning curiosity of like the
who how what where and when of this
incident totally
you ma'am and the vest which i am
feeling you
twins what is your curiosity and opinion
about this i'm always curious when it
comes to a double standard between what
happens to a man and then what happens
to a woman and then specifically what
happens to an african-american woman so
i'm very curious as to the dynamics
because it did seem like the fallout was
completely
unfair uncalled for
so
i'm pretty strong in those opinions yeah
agree i remember justin timberlake do
you apologize
that makes me feel less crazy because
that's exactly why i want to know
um and thank you for sharing that ross
well i i just remember justin timberlake
even apologized about how it all went
down so i'm hoping they're talking to
everybody to get to the bottom of what
happened and what they think about it
all these years later i'll be watching
for sure um okay next uh for all the
singles out there with dating app
fatigue we have a new concept for you
listen dating apps are here you can't
fight city hall but i am looking for
new angles or new refreshes i don't know
whatever you want to call them okay this
is really cool it's totally different
it's a dating app called thursday
and bustle reports that it only works on
guess what day
thursday
now you can only log in once a week
which i like because everybody's like
okay this is good boundaries for
everybody okay and only match if you're
actually free that night for an
in-person date which i'm assuming if
you're on the app thursdays you're free
that night
okay plus every week the app releases
the name of a secret singles only bar
somewhere in the city and this is what i
love because this is kicking it old
school i feel like you're kind of
bubbling like you're a part of a secret
society this is just so fun and then
making it even more magical all the
matches disappear that night at midnight
hello cinderella
that's right no but
and
let's just know that we all know
anything you ever put out there on that
cloud is going to last forever but we
can all fool ourselves thinking it
disappears at midnight and that's fun
this is a this is a no-go from me
let me tell you something anything you
want you've got to work for so if you
want a relationship you're going to be
out there trying to find i think maybe
we should decipher that it's probably
for people who
are
looking for fun and not maybe a
relationship oh well yeah if you want to
get it on thursday then you can get your
hair out
um
back in the day
i used to love secret like
you know say this word or the address is
like passed around it was all before
social media and it just made me feel
like a part of something and it was fun
and exciting show of hands if anybody
kind of likes that secret society action
right
like there's something really like
exciting about it you actually went to
bars and someone did say the code word
you did that thing of course i did all
over the globe i would like go to berlin
and go to like a secret club that was
happening that night i used to be so fun
[Applause]
yes i have no idea what happened to
normal people the coolest thing i ever
did was have like the promo code when i
checked out online at the gap
20 off that's the coolest thing i ever
did wow well guess what i am now in your
shoe
i am now mrs promo good i hope they're
20 off shoes
[Music]